time to play a game so this is one we
were talking about this before when we
were reading some quotes from from
Bernie Sanders and a Larson well no I
like Bernie Sanders because he really
believes what he says if you actually
look at his policies and his quotes
sometimes it's hard to tell the
difference between Bernie Sanders and in
the super super far left us yeah one
might argue that Bernie is super far
left himself so so it's time to play a
game that we call who said it this
edition is the Bernie Sanders or
communist condition so it's hard to know
now this can originally I was going to
be Bernie or Stalin Jared you know these
we don't know the answer to thee now do
you know these now you had to change
some of the language before people
change that couple some language just to
kind of give it even playing ground so
it wasn't like super obvious if someone
mentions a country name or country name
or billionaire class didn't exist back
then
just a little generalized well not
generalize you just change certain key
words that regionally sensitive or time
sensitive okay yes okay first quote who
said it
we are socialists we are enemies of
today's capitalistic economic system for
the exploitation of the economically
weak I'll tell you what I'll read it you
read the winners whether it's unfair
salaries with it's unseemly valuation of
a human being according to wealth and
property instead of responsibility in
performance and we are all determined to
destroy the system under all conditions
thank you okay Gerald who do you think
said this ah that sounds a lot like
Bernie you think that's Bernie
well I would say yeah I know that you so
you'd say Bernie well I would say in the
ideas okay in the idea this is not fair
I know that one I don't know the rest of
it I do know this we know this one
pretty sure that one is actually another
socialist Hitler number two let's see
this is code number two who said it all
right
election days come and go but the
struggle of the people to create a
government which represents all of us
and not just the 1% a government based
on the principles of economic social
racial and environmental justice that
struggle continues that's burning he
says the one percent I've got to say
that one is environmental
yeah I would say Bernie that's burning
it's burning it's only because of those
two keywords yeah don't forget the 1%
honestly it could have been anyone at
this but this could include what it
conclude like Mao Stalin Pol Pot Lenin
Marx all those people that killed Reza
who's a communist but only religion
kills okay let's go to another quote
this is the third quote who said it
enable every woman who can work to take
her place in the labor front under the
principle of equal pay for equal work ah
gosh you know what I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say Bernie on that I'm gonna say
Stalin you're just doing it because yeah
it's a it's a guess I'm gonna say Bernie
no it's not a guess he cared about women
right I generally thought that was
Bernie I thought it was Stalin I mean
you know okay and you can play along the
status your best quotes by the way those
who are watching either on YouTube or
mug Club members by outcome slush my
problem is we don't know which one is a
task runner or at Nike Jared you can
send your clothes to the skinnier
version of this game it's just there's
too many to pick from so Kenny let's
quote number 4 or 5 this is number 4
here before real change never takes
place from the top down or the living
rooms of the wealthy campaign
contributors I already think it's
burning all those occurs from the bottom
on up where tens of millions of people
say enough is enough and become engaged
in the fight for justice that's the
political resolution we helped start is
all about that's why the political
revolution must continue you know what I
was gonna say Bernie but I feel as
though this is a trick question because
that easily could have been stolen or
and since we've adapted the language to
make it contemporary Stalin yeah you
know what I'm gonna say Lenin actually
Lenin Gerald Wow I'm going Bernie gonna
burger and Bernie
all right we have yeah oh we can go for
days okay number five okay one who said
it for there is one thing we must never
forget the majority can never replace
the man well I think that almost sounds
a bit on the list the majority can never
replace the man or does that mean like
the man in a bad way and we're trying to
replace that I fight against the man I
am
I don't think Bernie's that poetic so
I'm gonna say I wanna say I'm gonna say
Stalin burly's a little more on the note
going back to Hitler you might say go
back to Hitler I'm gonna say Stalin not
sure I like knowing this
guess how much for Hitler being that
right-wing alright let's go let's go a
couple more here again you can send
yours for future okay the sandanista
government what is okay the Santa Anita
it's hard to read this font this Boogie
Nights font Satan Easter the Sandinista
government has more support among the
Nicaraguan people substantially more
support than Ronald Reagan has among the
American people
okay I think that's it can I can I say
what I think yeah I think that's an
old-school Bernie quote well see I was
gonna say I feel like it's a trick
because I would you would obviously say
something like Stalin or something like
you know Mao because it's older yeah or
someone maybe from North Korea or Fidel
Castro but because we've said it could
be an old-school Bernie cope but I'm
gonna say like I think I think Fidel
Castro a feel of Castro's that's good
guess Bernie that's three in a row
yeah well you just keep saying Bernie I
said the game is to try and get creative
with your guesses I said what not to be
right two more two more thanks for be is
you're a lot of fun at parties all right
put number at least seven before
consulting the hotheads who present
various military options such as
military invasion remember President
Reagan Rambo only exists in the movies
okay I'm gonna say that one I'll say uh
Bernie
it can't be Castro a caster I'm gonna
give it Castro really I think that one's
Bernie likes an old-school Bernie well
the options a lot of horrible so there
are I mean leaders they've all failed
and yet we listen to birdie okay let's
wrap Jarrell Jared picked the best one
nah keep it to us okay bye find me a
second here I'm gonna find okay that's
one year let's see
boom alright the greed of the bourgeois
has got to end and we are going to end
it for them who oh that's Lenin that
could easily be Bernie Marx Bernier Marx
you know to talk you saying Lenin dnal
I'll save Marx I'll send Marx to
billionaire class oh the same thing yeah
yeah was originally intended to be a
family-friendly fun game huh is a heart
tremoring Li terrified because now he
just announced that he's going to be
running for president again in 2020 when
he's 700 yeah he's a going to be running
for president in 2020 so I am genuinely
scared I thought we'd get a couple get a
few that we missed send yours to us and
tell us what you think about this course
of the extremists or the not actually
misses a not fair is it fair is it just
good old-fashioned fun I know you don't
have that in a youtube comment section
like this video subscribe by clicking
the subscribe button it's a Kitson it's
a circle now it used to be a square
which most buttons aren't squares let's
it's on a phone there's square buttons
on phones what most buttons are circles
you understand what I'm talking about or
watch the recommended video which is
popping up in a box or subscribe at a
lotta with better calm slash menthe club
join them on clip so you can get the
Daily Show and that means that you are
not beholden to the YouTube censoring
overlords let's be honest you like being
there where you are under their thumb
power bottom you